good evening ladies and gentlemen whoo
welcome to the Chubb fellowship lecture
with Shahrukh Khan and collaboration of
the South Asian society in 1949 Yale
alumnus Hendon Chubb funded a speaking
fellowship to promote the notion that
service to the public good is the
highest calling to which a citizen can
aspire
according to visiting speaker to be
named a Chubb fellow as years most
notable honor chop fellows have included
national heads of state international
leaders Nobel and Pulitzer Prize winners
and a wide range of highly accomplished
individuals in politics business science
and the arts the experiences and
leadership of these individuals have
helped define the challenges of our
times and the way that we should seek to
address them all of us at Yale are
exceptionally proud to be the first
American University to honor mr. Conn
[Music]
mr. Conn who waited for your arrival
eagerly and having you with us is
nothing short of a dream I'm sure
everyone in the audience agrees with me
too
[Applause]
let me just get a general sense how many
of y'all have dreamt of seeing mr. Shah
Rukh Khan
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen all lucky 1700 a
few imagine 300 thousand times the
number of people in this room around
three billion people three times the
population of India or approximately one
and every two people in the world that
is the number of people that recognize
mr. Khan globally eleven eleven of his
movies have grossed over a billion
dollars he's been nominated for some 200
awards won around 150 of which 11 have
been the prestigious best after Filmfare
Award and of course in addition to all
of this he stole in the heart of
countless and countless girls it is only
natural that he's fondly referred to as
King Khan not only has he ruled
Bollywood for the last two decades but
he's also reigned over the hearts of
millions and millions of people I want
to share a little story about how
wonderful a person mr. Khan is a very
long time ago when I was a newly
admitted ele I'd excitedly ask mr. Khan
if he would come visit here and he'd
very politely said yes and expressed how
important it was to him to engage with
students this year when I was elected
president of the South Asian society I
decided to take him up on his offer and
so over winter break I asked him again
and he very graciously said anytime you
call me and so I waited for April which
is a South Asian Awareness Month to
invite him not realizing that April is
the busiest month on his schedule yet
because of the commitment he'd made four
years ago mr. Khan took time out to fly
all the way to New Haven from Bombay
just to be with us for the day it is
this amazing quality of going out of his
way to spread happiness that will never
let mr. Khan leave our dreams
speaking of Dreams how many turn of
gemmed to see mr. Khan but never thought
of translate into reality there are a
few people who need to be thanked for
translating this dream into reality
first and most foremost master Branson
and Timothy Dwight college without whom
this event would have never been at the
scale that it is mr. George Joseph the
Office of International Affairs in the
India initiative for the immense
patience and generous support the South
Asia Film Society for running the Shah
Rukh Khan Film Festival the Yale Office
of Public Affairs for helping realizes
mammoth event my South Asian society
board so all the hard work and taking
sass to new levels a membership for
being so enthusiastic about the events
and last but not the least I'd like to
thank my mother and Shahrukh Khan for
making this dream come true ladies and
gentlemen
it is our honor to present you for the
first time in an American University the
batch of bollywood king khan shahrukh
khan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much it's
really nice to be here and I love you
too yeah good evening it's really nice
to be here finally yeah it was a long
flight Thank You Nita for getting me
here thank you for having me over here
and we would detain at the airport as
always for an hour and a half which was
nice yeah it always happens it's nice
you know whenever I start feeling too
arrogant about myself I always take a
trip to America in the immigration guys
kick the star out of stardom and well I
have my small victories you know they
always ask me how tall I am and I always
lie and get away five feet ten inches
next time I'm going to be more
adventurous what color you I'm gonna say
white well okay so I'm supposed to be
serious here because this is for
students and kids so first of all let me
just thank the faculty and students of
the Yale University fellows of Timothy
Dwight College and the chopped
fellowship and master Geoffrey Brent
self for being so kind thank you Yale
Office of International Affairs and the
Yale South Asian Society and of course
Asia for dealing and following up with
the most disorganized and
incommunicative person in the world
which is me to fix today's meeting with
you all I'm really really happy very
humble very honored and thank you for
having me
[Applause]
like I have memories of I've been here
before five years ago I was here in Yale
I was doing the song some of the shots
you know the ones at the graveyard they
were shot here and none and it was very
cold it was I think 5th or 6th of
December it was snowing here and I
remember I was doing a song from Kabhi
Alvida Na Kehna in the middle yeah and I
was I was trying to kiss Rani Mukerji
while mouthing the words we do that in
Bollywood for all the guys who don't
know how it is yeah we sing songs and we
try to kiss girls at the same time and
and I I'm being honest my mouth froze in
the middle of Kabhi Alvida
yeah lockjaw yeah so I'm I'm hoping my
second outing to Yale is a little better
because otherwise it just won't sound
right if I was to get stuck on I don't
know what you guys call yourself
Yale tides yellers it yeah yeah that
well I hope I don't get stuck at yeah
and go beyond that so I was told not to
dwell too much on my movies when I spoke
to you I am to give you an inspirational
talk tell you stuff you can think about
when you leave this room now that
worries me gives me performance anxiety
about 1,500 of you here hoping to hire
words of wisdom from the sexy desire old
man who couldn't kiss a girl last time
he was in Yale because it was too cold
but I am I want to until you right in
the beginning I'm not that guy
I'm telling I mean I'm sexy and
desirable but I'm but I'm not about to
leave you any more inspired than you
were when you walked in here and I did
this lame joke on Google yes I I go to
Google and search everything there even
my next script I'm searching on Google
now and the joke was like this a dying
man gasping for breath desperately
gestured to the priest by his sight for
a piece of paper with great effort he
then wrote a few words on it handed to
the priest and passed away the priest
kept the paper in his pocket and forgot
all about it until the final service
here he suddenly recalled the Dead Man's
last scribble and folding the paper he
told the funeral congregation that he
was about to read great words of
inspiration from the dying man
he opened the paper the piece of paper
had these words on it he was standing on
my oxygen tube you fool so I'm I'm gonna
be kind of like that priest don't expect
words of wisdom from me I'm just gonna
tell you my life journey in very simple
words and which may not leave you
inspired but will help you survive this
life and if you can do that kids if you
can survive happiness creativity and
success will follow on its own only I
hope my words will give you enough
insight when you hear the story that I
have to tell you that you can tell the
world world
move over you're standing on my oxygen
tube I need to breathe air
so journeys can be defined by age and
time or even by destinations as most
often they are but I feel it's hard for
me to tell you this
story of my life in those terms because
the concept of time has always eluded me
the day my father died seemed longer
than my entire childhood the day I felt
my first success seemed fleetingly along
not long enough perhaps I wondered where
it went even the cycle of time confounds
me I worked the knock I worked the dark
until sunrise on most days and fall
asleep as the world awakens to light my
friends call me an owl I like to think
of myself as bat Batman
the Prince of Darkness I I some of you
would know I have a superhero fetish so
I keep bringing this back it's age is
not my forte either
I still cannot fix my own am I 45 or 15
if I could would I be romancing girls
one-third my age who normally would call
me uncle I had so much fun collecting
the action figures of my last film
called Robin that yeah
that none of the critical reviews
tanking my film affected me at all
and as for my destination I don't think
I have a new one I walk I run in the
direction of my dreams things change
along the way people change I change the
world changes and even my dreams change
I don't have a place to arrive I just
keep doing what I know how to do the
best that I can do it I'll probably end
up deluded geriatric in a wheelchair
wearing a cape and tights imagining my
moon flight out of this world but of
course with a young girl in my arms so
I'll tell you the story of me but I'll
tell it in my own way in the language of
my perceptions in the things I think
matter beyond Fame success and the dying
of my grey hair I have understood that
the measure of my life lies in the
expanse of my hearts experience and
nothing else matters
if you take anything out of it good
otherwise I've been told by the master I
can put on music and dance for you on
chammak challo
[Applause]
okay so first of all yeah we do that
later I know I know I you know people
call me to these serious places and then
say oh [ __ ] everything just do the
dance and go back oh man but I insist
you listen to me okay
okay I want to tell you I have to tell
you that I learned a few big words
because I was coming to Yale okay on
Google of course and I so the first one
that I'm gonna tell you about so there's
three things I wanna tell you about this
evening the first one is I'm going to
tell you to be a few Namba list now yeah
that's a big we're impressed so that
means a tightrope walker because a lot
of you people actually all of you
somehow are the are going to create
things in your life so a fine ambulance
is like a type of tightrope walker okay
so the first word I'll um please give me
claps for this new word that I've taught
Yale however I look at it in its
eventual analysis my life has centered
around my creativity
I have assimilated the world through
creative expression and return the world
has experienced me hopefully I've grown
to understand that on one hand the world
will always uphold creativity as the
most honest feeling possible on the
other hand the portents of Fame the
glitz the glamour the wealth that arise
from this very recognition of creativity
will always be questioned why do we do
that because sometimes it allows us to
feel better than the Creator and
sometimes it fills a void within us that
comes about but being in awe of his or
her creation either way it enables us to
quantify his or her engagement
engagement with the world around him I'm
an actor
my life is a testament to this duality
George Burns said their acting is all
about honesty if you can figure it made
and he couldn't have defined it better
honest and fake yes that's what I feel
as a creative person all the time let me
tell you my schizophrenia
creative expression comes from the
deepest experience of the artist himself
a good artist cannot be separate from
his creation good art is honest at a man
may be an artist a writer a sculptor an
actor or a totem pole cava whatever he
is if what he creates is true to himself
it becomes a vivid testimony
to human creativity if it lacks honesty
it is entire its entire premise is a
waste at the same time and quite
paradoxically a man becomes distinct
from his creation from the moment it is
placed in the public domain it no longer
even belongs to him
so it comes from your gut and it is put
out there for others to accept it or
throw it in the gutter many nights I
have gone back home after receiving an
award pumped up and all happy and just
to read on the internet that what I
really deserved was the golden banana
for the worst actor of the Year award
yeah it's called kala Awards or some
[ __ ] like that yeah and i become
heartbroken angry and completely
convinced that bananas and critics both
should have their skins peeled and fed
to the monkeys i momentarily lose my
ability to give and close up and here's
where the trick is when you are in this
place of despair when you walk out of
this college this university and walk
the path of life with the world is
tearing you down into yourself there's
only one thing you can do to survive
hang on to who you are inside the world
will be unkind to you it will not be
able to see you you must learn at such
times to be able to see yourself life as
a created person is like walking on a
tightrope I have to keep balancing I
have to keep the balance I begin to lose
myself in my own melodrama it is
frustrating that I find myself living up
to other people's interpretation of what
I ought to be and when faced with
dissent or unappreciated I start losing
my love affair with my own audience it
becomes a tight balance act to keep
doing what I do best
and not be bothered by the reactions of
the people I do it for in the first
place
I dance harder I caught three longer and
I pirouette on my rope stretched taut
beneath my feet and I try not to slip I
can slide but never fall and all this
while I have to keep a smile on my face
and keep signing autographs and taking
pictures and why do I do this because
I'm a few Namba list trying to balance
my action an exterior reaction to my
naked show of Who I am inside
yet when I'm playing this real-life
illusion out more
not my honest self is sitting in the
audience applauding my performance while
laughing heartily at my own stupidity so
my little kids and friends here learn to
laugh at yourself to never become
cynical about yourself or your life
becoming cynical about your life is the
single most destructive thing you can do
for you have to remember creativity is
your gift to the world it was never
meant to be barter for anything not even
appreciation you have to dig deep I do
it I don't know if I'm supposed to say
this I'd do it while drinking vodka and
listening to really sorry songs but you
guys have to find less destructive ways
to do this at least till you become my
age but you have to believe that you
create only because this is the biggest
gift you have to give to your world and
maybe that's why we even call God a
creator it's not about the cars or
houses
it never was these are peripherals they
never come about because of your talent
or your creative outpourings they come
out of a business that people around you
do those people are in the business of
bata not you
yours is the business of giving and
learning your work of art may never be
complete in your lifetime your
fulfillment will always lie in your
creative expression not in its product
so look beyond the brick Bats the
critics and know within you that you
always have a choice between barter and
creation life as a Creator will always
be a tightrope so do not try to feed
your stomach with creativity it is food
for the soul not your stomach do not be
afraid to do defy conventions do not be
afraid to destroy systems that kill art
and your souls do not be afraid to be
hungry and do not be afraid to walk
alone if necessary
because on a tightrope we all walk alone
and remember if you are a creator you're
a fine ambulance and not very many
people know what it means let alone be
it so be a phenom ballast is my prayer
to all you creative people here at Yale
tonight
the second thing I want to tell you and
I'll go over it fast
before you get too bored is love your
punching bags just as my life has
centered around creativity like every
fellow human beings that has also
centered around the wish to find
happiness your age is the age when we
most confuse happiness with
gratification so I will quite plainly
tell you if you are smart if you want to
survive life through Lent set relentless
onslaught of challenges you will sooner
or later understand that the things that
make you happy ten years ago will end up
being the ones that make you happy when
you hit the geriatric superheat stage
also so kids start collecting your
action figure heroes now I have
everything I could have aspired for at
your age
I have success I fame I have wealth and
I have three Playstations I do I have
one for the house one for shootings and
one just in case because I can have one
more
but none of these but but none of these
have any consequence to my happiness the
only thing that does it is the love of
my children you don't have children
I hope not yet and if you have don't
tell the master but you have parents and
you have people you love and nothing in
this world of everything's means more
than that happiness in other word lies
and the things you will never be able to
count to me it is no more than cuddling
to my kids and watching iCarly or the
Family Guy yeah
are they doing Family Guy's way cool and
then I think iCarly's also very good
most of the time I do that the other day
my son and I stumbled upon Kama Sutra on
the net and I can tell you that
experience was not very happy he's 14
and he knew more about the poses than I
did that's not yeah I want you to
understand this business of happiness
well because I know at one level all
parents actually the same some look
sterner some are less fun some
embarassingly weird but for each fair in
the bottom and the top line of their
lives is this you kids are the greatest
source of happiness pens won nothing
written just that you respect that
feeling that's all I'd like to narrate
an incident of my own children first of
all let me be very clear I do believe
girls are from the planet Venus my girl
comes from a place of gentleness caring
love intelligent and all things
beautiful my boy comes from I'm too good
to be your son planet
and I know I know this might make me
very unpopular but I wanted to say this
while I was flying here that if one
thing that you take away from this
lecture tonight I want everyone to know
boys are obnoxious yeah they are
philandering lying cheating supercilious
sneering snobs I girls are good yeah
Larry Kyoko botanically as I can report
ahead well I believe that I like girls I
think girls are much better I was in
London shooting and missing my kids and
I'll give you an instance being from the
boarding school of people who sent
writings to their kids in the hope of
making them better human beings I sent
my daughter this verse from a poem by EE
Cummins and you guys should read the
read the poet is fantastic and this poem
is for all the girls here so I want to
read this out I do not know what it is
about you that closes and opens only
something in me understands the voice of
your eyes is deeper than all roses
nobody not even the rain has such small
hands and this for all you girls and the
only smaller hands I guess this little
kid who is crying there but we I send
this message to my daughter and I
instantly receive this text message in
return I love it Popeye it is beautiful
I'm going to write it in my secret diary
with the secret lock and keep it in my
secret hiding place under the Katy Perry
and Lady Gaga post and I love you and I
miss you I'm too excited watching Hunger
Games tonight
and feeling feelings bad feeling bad
that I hadn't texted something
meaningful to my darling son I sent him
something I had read to how are you my
son I wrote I missed you do you know a
boy someone that a mother loves the most
little girls hate him he is truth with
dirt on its face beauty with the cut on
its finger wisdom would smell in its
hair and hope of the future with a frog
in its pocket
I love you he replied back with one
letter of the alphabet now actually is
very close to you it had a button front
and says butt and it had the why of Yale
why
are you like why you sending such boring
messages and of course there was an
emoticon one of those squiggly little
things which I can't make out what
they're expressing I wanted to fly to
Mumbai and hang him upside down upside
down till it looked like a silly face
emoticon himself but I didn't I just
smiled and both replies made me feel
love for my kids whatever they do as
long as they are happy it makes me happy
so I speak to you as a parent of two
very weird kids whatever you do
whichever mistake you make however you
react to them your parents are your best
friends they might be boring City or
Stern at times maybe some of you're
embarrassed of yours I know my kids are
of me but if ever any of your in trouble
of any kind the best friends you can
always trust to watch your backs are
your parents they will always come good
I lost my parents very early in my life
and I miss them dearly so all of you who
still have yours don't listen to them
fool them if you must a bit of lying is
also welcome but make sure you cherish
what you have because when you don't
have them like me you really miss
someone to be rude to someone too you
can to someone you can take for granted
someone to say and do whatever you wish
with you miss the comfort of being loved
unconditionally I call parents
unconditional and forgiving punching
bags who feel happiest when they get
bashed up by the kids if you want to
survive life it's best to begin to
respect the gift of love right now as
children your first teachers of this
acceptance are your parents if you're
unable to accept the love they give you
in whatever form it arrives even if it's
in the form of a tight slap across your
faces then when you become a parent you
will end up having to learn this lesson
somewhat more harshly from teachers you
give birth to those are your kids and
learning Kama Sutra from my son is not a
great idea you would agree incidentally
he studies in the school that ishes mom
runs in India I have to say ma'am your
syllabus is quite different from the one
I used to study when I was 14
[Applause]
she is she's insisting that she will get
kamasutra inhale also very soon and the
last way a fiendish friend called
failure whether I like it or not my life
has also been in constant play with what
the world calls success success is a
wonderful thing but it tends not to be
the sort of experience that we learn
from we enjoyed perhaps we even deserve
it but we don't acquire wisdom from it
and maybe that's why it cannot be passed
on either me being successful does not
mean my kids are going to be successful
even if I teach them everything that I
know and how to do it so I feel that
talking about success is completely a
big waste of time instead let me tell
you very honestly whatever happened to
me happened because I've always been
terrified of failure I don't want as
much to succeed as much as I don't want
to fail I come from a very normal lower
middle-class family I saw a lot of
failure my father was a beautiful man
and the most successful failure in the
world my mother also failed to stay long
long enough with me to see me become a
big movie star we were quite poor
actually and let me tell you poverty is
not an ennobling experience at all
poverty entails fear and stress and
sometimes depression I watched my
parents go through this several times at
an early age after my parents died I
equated poverty with failure I just
didn't want to be poor so when I got a
chance to act in films it wasn't out of
any creative desire I say this honestly
it was purely out of the fear of failure
and poverty most of the films I signed
with discards of better known actors and
the producers could not find anyone else
to do them I did them all to make sure
that I was working to avoid unemployment
the timing or something was right I
worked very hard there were other people
around it and I became a big star the
films became big hits which means
sometimes a success is not the direct
result of actions and let nobody tell
you that success sometimes just happens
really it is accidental and we have to
take credit for it I do it sometimes
surely out of embarrassment
so I believe the true path to success is
through the fear of failure if you
aren't scared enough to are failing
you're unlikely to succeed it's not
pleasant to fail it's tough all of us
experience it you will too if you
haven't already so use it to succeed how
I've done is a few points I'd like to
say and then I'll end this monologue
firstly it's not the absence of failure
that makes you success that that makes
success it is your response to failure
that actually helps to buffer the
reverses that you experience I
personally have one response to failure
like Matt ISM a recognition and believe
that if one approach does not work then
the other will or might failure also
gives me an incentive to greater the
greater exertion harder work which
invariably leads to later success in
most cases repeated failure has taught
me to stop pretending I'm someone else
it's given me the clarity to stick to
things that really matter to me instead
of distracting me from my core failure
also gets you to find who your real
friends are the true strength of your
relationships only gets tested in the
face of strong adversity overcoming some
of my failures has made me discover that
I have a strong will and more discipline
that I suspected it has helped me to
have confidence in my ability to survive
failure is an amazing teacher there's a
well-known story of this very successful
man and a reporter asked him sir how is
it that you always succeed and he said
right decisions how do you make right
decisions and he says you know
experience how do you get so experienced
is wrong decisions and failure so do
fail and it's alright to fail you have
to know and learn that life is not just
a checklist of acquisitions attainments
and fulfillments your qualifications and
Seavey's don't really matter
instead life is difficult and
complicated and beyond anyone's control
the humility to know it will help you
survive its vicissitudes this is the
second big word that I'd learned
but I don't want to sound dark my whole
fall of you is that you retain a
lifelong love of learning that you never
cease to dream exciting and inspiring
dreams and when you fail you don't and
you fail you fail well enough to succeed
the next time don't be afraid of being
afraid be afraid of not facing your
fears and failures as I was coming here
and this is my dream I was telling the
press outside when I walked in here I
sent a message to my little daughter
who's 11 and a half my son 14 and I said
it's one of the most beautiful
institutions I've seen in my life
genuinely you guys are fortunate to be
studying here and and everything I
really wish my kids are good enough like
you all you young boys and girls and all
the parents who've helped them do this
are good enough to reach here and study
and get this opportunity so I wrote to
my daughter and said so pretty and nice
and beautiful I wish you could come and
study here and she sent me back a long
message as she always does is it pretty
Papa is it nice is it snowing there
because I told the last time I was there
it was snowing and my son sent me one
alphabet K which I have understood when
you extend means okay yeah and for some
reason he's also written Papa Chuck
Norris has trained his dog to pick up
its own poop because Chuck Norris will
not take [ __ ] from anyone
so
so remember all boys and girls there you
are fortunate enough to be few Namba
lists you have an amazing scent of
punching bags your parents cherish them
always and failure is your fiendish
friend keep him close and as my son sent
a message don't take no [ __ ] from
anybody god bless you thank you very
much
thank you all very kind and I wish you
all the best in life thank you very much
thank you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well hello everyone again I've
discovered I've discovered that if I
ever become a movie star you can't see a
thing up here no not a thing
so my name is Jeff bren's Elle I'm the
Dean of Admissions here at Yale these
are my people
I'm the master of Timothy Dwight College
a lecturer in the Department of
Philosophy and I keep the flame for the
Chubb fellowship which I'm incredibly
happy to say it's brought SRK to New
Haven so I just want to tell him right
now in front of God and everybody here
that I think his chances for admission
here to Yale would be pretty good and
we're hoping he's going to have time to
drop by the office to fill out the
application before he leaves so here
with me to ask a few questions is Nikhil
Sood who was born and brought up in New
Delhi India and attended Saint Columbus
school which was SRK school he then came
to Yale where he received his bachelor's
in economics in 2010 economics just like
SRK it gets more eerie as you go while
at Yale actually he departed from
Shahrukh's career and he founded Yale
Hindi debate a national level
competition in the United States that
takes place entirely in the Hindi
language and it's now in its fifth year
he's currently a student at the Yale Law
School
we're going for a dual language country
here sooner or later well he hasn't yet
charted out his career plans he did tell
me that he's got one goal to get mr.
shahrukh khan to follow him on twitter
no not yet he hasn't achieved this goal
yet then we have Sarika arya who
graduated from Yale College in 2011 with
a double major in ethics politics and
economics and also theatre studies her
parents emigrated from India to America
where she and her brother were born and
raised until they moved to London for
several years while here at Yale Sarika
studied International Affairs human
rights activism and the use of theater
to impact social change she's currently
working as a Woodbridge Hall Fellow at
the Yale Office of International Affairs
next year she's off to London School of
Economics so please welcome the guests
[Applause]
we had some questions everyone had their
own particular question that they wanted
to ask you okay
and we're gonna start with Nikhil hello
mr. Khan
I thought you spoke really truly
inspiring Lee about valuing creativity
and about facing your fears my concern
is I feel there are many students out
there who are passionate about
creativity and are also generally brave
people who can face their fears but in
spite of this they choose safer more
traditional non creative paths in life
because they feel the creative path is
simply too risky no matter how brave
they are and even though they love
creativity for its own sake not for
bartering it for money they feel they'd
still need to be able to pay the bills
and that might not happen so for a
person who is devoted to the Arts but
due to certain practical realities of
the world selects a non creative part is
it possible for such a person to lead a
truly happy fulfilling life on a
personal note I'm really worried because
I'm a huge fan of creative writing and I
did a lot of that in school and at
college but now I've chosen law school
and I console myself by saying so what
if you're not writing movies or TV shows
you still be writing legal briefs and
legal memos and I think you know while
on some level that makes sense I think
it's an extremely depressing thought and
I do feel like somebody's stepping on my
oxygen tea but I fear that the
alternative might feel like somebody
simply cut off my oxygen to you because
I won't be able to pay my bills
so my question really is and I ask this
on behalf of everyone like me can I be
happy and it's so hot
[Applause]
Nega let me tell you you've got problems
dude but I tell you how I've done it you
know I did theater and I truly believe
in being very creative very artistic and
a very serious actor at times I really
do when I see a lot of work that has
been done around by other actors in my
own country and outside I feel envious
at times that I've not been able to do
that because like you said when I came
on to Mumbai and I will say this to all
the kids that yes
surviving is the most that's what the
whole speech was that you have I'll
teach you how to survive you know I'm
not gonna give you any thoughts about
that listen it's all right to you know
go on top of mlainez and do your writing
creative writing what anyone reads it or
not know it's important that people read
it it's important it becomes a
best-seller as a matter of fact I very
shamelessly say I am the most capitalist
human being that you will ever find on
the face of this earth I truly believe
that you need to find a place where you
can make the choices that you want to
make you cannot just say you know I had
a friend who was was a creative writer
and who fortunately still is not a
lawyer and he wanted to write books and
he's working here in America in New York
actually been and he asked me one day
his father died and he said you know I
want to write books I won't write
creative stuff on spirituality and
goodness and I don't want to like
anything else how am I gonna survive my
father's dead my mother's not being able
to look after me and I said you know you
go down and you know start working in a
advertising company where he started
writing I do remember you know we this
is a joke we had in college I don't know
if it is still here you know it was an
inner where and you know with a you know
like a Calvin Klein underwear model and
you write it's for everyone every Tom
Dick and Harry
and so which you say if you write this
stuff you write it and earn the money
payables don't let them cut your oxygen
tube out but after you are in that
position of choice don't misuse it and
that's the one thing that I was I
decided to do I do not of advertising a
lot of people question me on the
uncreated bits of work that I do I do I
think out of ten things that I do I
think seven of them are highly uncreated
highly and creative and very disturbing
at times I have a big bathroom now I sit
there and cry after having done those
things yeah I genuinely do I'm not lying
I want I want kids to notice that yeah I
do that I get I'm like I don't want to
do this but I take the money from that
and I would like to be able to create a
produce a production house a filmmaking
institution which would do the creative
stuff which I wanted to do when I was 25
it may get a little late it may happen
when I'm 50 or 55 may not have happened
when I dreamed of it at 26 27 but I'm
sure that I will make the right choices
so please all your kids do not get
waylaid by anyone who tells you it's a
wonderful to be creative and poor and
hungry no you can't be that you have to
survive your petty way to your parents
you owe it to your life be well have
good cars have a good television have
three Playstations if you need but when
you get into that position of choice
make sure you don't cheat with your
choices so that's one thing so do your
legal briefs and on the side when you
have become this really famous wonderful
lawyer saving convicts and
and criminals go into that bathroom cry
a bit that you saved another criminal
today but with the money that you earn
from that mafia don right all right
sorry so India is the country of
hundreds of languages cultures religions
customs and so on and as a result the
country grapples with divisive nasaan
many social issues but your films have
created a truly devoted and United fan
base that's united in their love of you
Shahrukh Khan and they're they're
uniting across ethnic and national
boundaries even outside of India yet at
the same time some of your films do deal
with social issues so my name is Khan it
confronted racial profiling after 9/11
and Chak De India discussed bigotry and
sexism those are the stories that I
write
um but at the same time we also do have
films that are sheer entertainment so
what is it about your work that appeals
to and unites audiences that are
normally at odds with each other and
also do you feel that films have or
maybe they already have a role in
discussing or examining social issues I
mean I think they have but if they make
it the prime concern then they don't
remain so they don't remain
entertainment I say this to everyone
it's a little saying that you know
messages are for the post box post
offices they're not for entertainment
you don't give messages through
entertainment I'm a big believer of that
you need to entertain people you know
two and a half hours in a dark room come
back have fun and enjoy yourselves and
entertainment can be sad it can be more
but it can be bright it can be colorful
it can be as silly as some of the films
that I do but I I truly believe that the
reason I think I was analyzing it I keep
analyzing it because everyone keeps
asking me how did this happen that
people everywhere like you and I I
cannot go beyond the answer that has to
do with my dimples is the most
intellectual answer I've been able to
give myself yeah
and you see how far you go with these
distances but but I think the reason
that my cinema or the kind of films that
I think I got a little fortunate that in
the 90s when I started working there was
a time when eighties was the time of you
know a lot of aggressive films and ugly
bell-bottoms and big collars and strange
hairstyles in Indian cinema and somehow
the younger generation which was kind of
me also that time was 24 23 they all
wanted to have a little more love amidst
them you know not anti-establishment
work not anti-social work they just
wanted to have feeling of love and I
think I did a lot of films like that so
whether it was Dilwale Dulhaniya Le
Jayenge Kuch Kuch Hota Hai and I think I
think as cliched as it may sound but it
makes me believe that love really is the
universal language you know so you can
be in a country with hundred different
languages as you stayed and I come down
to Yale to America to London I go to
South America and people in Germany who
don't speak a language at all and and
you know they they all they all seem to
like that cinema I asked one lady a six
year old lady who actually took the
first Indian film to Germany she used to
work for a big television studio and I
asked her so I was sitting with her at
night and I said why do you want to do
anything why do you guys like in the
film you know I go and shoot in Germany
and there like hundreds of Germans who
love a film yeah and they don't speak
Hindi at all which is October October
after no no and you know nothing they
make these guttural sounds but they
don't speak
and and you know they they look very
imposing because from the outside we all
have preset notions of each country and
country people from there and I asked
them I said why do you like Hindi films
why do you like this kind of cinema so
they told me that I have a button to
drive a car I put on a button
the car starts I have a button to make
coffee I have a button to go up and down
in Germany we didn't have a button to
cry and you give us that button you're
fools
give us that button and I think you know
and and and so I equate these two things
I think love as beautiful light as as it
is also makes you cry and in a good way
sometimes in a bad way but I think the
the togetherness of this I think the
whole human community around the world
you will find to universal truths they
all love and they all cry and I think if
your work if you are writing if your job
can deal with that without knowing it
you will be bringing social changes you
don't need to make an attainment I think
you just need to say the truth and say
you know this is a little about love for
a father son for a father daughter for a
man woman for a mother son for a teacher
student it's a little about crying and
when you write stories like that or show
stories like that or incidents like that
I think it just unites us because we all
do go into that bathroom and cry so we
all have that bathroom and I think we
all feel like loving so I think yeah I
think if you keep it as simple as loving
and crying
each cinema each theater everything will
have its social
the man who gave the Germans permission
to cry a light that's fantastic Sarika
honestly if it weren't for my good
friends here amongst so many South Asian
students and faculty here at Yale I
wouldn't know your films South Asian
Film Society has been spreading the
spray in the gospel here a lot of people
were becoming attracted to this cinema
but of course I came
not as these two students but as an
outsider you know to Indian cinema
I'd heard of something called Bollywood
and I fell into the trap that many of us
do of thinking that actually meant
something you know that it was something
some kind of relation to Hollywood and
then when I first started watching the
films I realize there's no there's no
Hollywood take off here that's not
what's going on they the films were like
nothing I'd ever seen they had their own
language they had their own world they
had their own way of seeing things
mostly I have to say this incredible
enthusiasm for life they were
fantastically original which was just a
startling experience I didn't know of
the existence of this world so I wanted
to ask you what do you see happening as
Bollywood as Indian film as Indian
cinema you're always doing something new
but that that influence is expanding
it's moving out into the world and some
in some very remarkable ways is India
movie making influencing Western movie
making is Western movie making creeping
into to Indian cinema or these ships
passing in the night are they talking to
each other I think you know what a
cinema is very unique and I remember
here in Quentin Tarantino at Cannes and
he said the only reason and and I just
want to point out it's the only film
industry in the world which has survived
Hollywood yes yeah all the other film
industries where there's Japan or any
place in Europe the local cinema
kind of has been taken over by the more
popular commercial wonderful Hollywood
cinema that is made I'm a big fan
India has survivor we still make the
largest number of films and the reason
for that is that we still believe in
stars we believe that they're people who
can lead us we don't think a movie star
is just a professional we look up to him
or her we think of them AHA as role
models I'm the wrong one don't ever do
that I and I've been hiding in the gully
and smoking and stuff I'm a bad boy but
but but you know the whole system of
looking up to someone or trying to find
a hero has made Indian cinema survive
having said that our stories are very
unique very culturally based and of
course we have this uniqueness of what
used to happen in the 60s in Hollywood
we are musicals yes we break into a song
and dance any time so so yeah yeah right
like he was saying it so kindly
because he was he was being he was being
so wonderful they said you know I was
talking by them
it's bloody shocking watch what we do on
speed yeah I know why are they dancing
yeah we do that and actually my ovens
are like a variety show a cavity yeah
yeah because like she said we have
hundred languages we still live in one
family households so the grand moms
there the grand child is there the great
grandchild is there and all of us
watching cinema is the only escapist
route we have in our country we don't
have skins clubs we don't have car
racing we've got a little bit of sports
coming in a television just started so
what happens is you need to have that
area where you want to say listen I'm
not bothered about life or these two and
a half hours I'm going to be overwrought
by this fund and the GRANDMONT says I
want to hear actually something
spiritual so we put spiritual and and
she says I want to see this cool guy
with dimples dancing it's okay and you
say I need to be startled so yes
totaling you so we we put everything in
it you know and and unabashedly so yeah
and happily so and celebrate life
because life I think has all of it put
in you know life has never been that you
don't sing you think while shaving and
you have a fine and there's no isolation
of emotions
in real life everything is happening
together and it's wonderful when I see
Western cinema that it isolates emotions
it's more linear there's more
storytelling there's more
character-driven stuff but I think a
cinema because it was just celebration
and celebrated it makes you feel a
little attracted to it you know you say
okay let it be now and if somebody's
gonna sit down and what does it have fun
a lot of Technology from Hollywood
people like myself and the younger
actors and directors want to take it on
because I think technically the Western
cinema is about 40 to 50 years ahead of
us and we need to bring it to India
that's the only way we will be able to
come down come up in the international
market we are about zero zero two
percent of world market as far as
economics go
we didn't make the maximum number of
films but in terms of economics we are
very small the only way we can do that
is not change the language of our films
the technology and the techn
of storytelling you know we do it and we
have we do films and three acts we have
an interval you know I was I was I have
to tell you this incident I made a film
called Ashoka which was about Gautam
Buddha an assault is a gate for my
thought and unfortunately situ had to
mention it I'd released on 9/11 so it
kind of Tang didn't do well and I was I
was showing it to an English set of
audience just before I came here and and
and the film went on and on and it's
really long we make three hour long yeah
and so before they all entered so I had
all these British people saying why do
you guys have the interval J way of
doing what does it mean wait why should
we why should we have to break into the
air
it breaks the whole sequencing of a
story tone besides that I'm sorry but we
have an interval after one and a half
hours they were like holding my hand why
don't you guys have the interval now so
our cinema looks after everybody's wants
and desires as well as in when they crop
up
but yeah there is a whole mix together I
think technically if we do better we'll
have more world cinema audience going
watching it and story wise I think our
stories are about hope and simple hopes
you know and they're not too outlandish
though it seems so sometimes everyone
tells me Indian cinema is unrealistic
but it's as realistic as the President
of the United States sitting in Air
Force One and going and destroying a
meteor and we say wow yeah it can happen
but as unrealistic and I think the
stories should remain culturally bound
in terms of the simple hoops and simple
ideologies while the technology I think
we should start taking and we are
already from Hollywood a lot of studios
have now opened up in India and there's
this huge give-and-take and it's
fantastic for world cinema I think and I
I I'm here in America and I'm not doing
because I'm here but I didn t want to
thank all the studios in Hollywood
because I've been interacting with them
in the last 560 my name is Han was
actually made by Fox and they were kind
enough to release it and she would
really like it to be shown to everyone
so there's this huge synergies that are
happening yeah and I think yeah
Indian cinema is really gaining from it
and hopefully one day you'll not be so
startled by her films
so so so just some advice for my fellow
white people who are not Germans in the
audience because I know that you haven't
washed enough of these films this is
something to go home now and do and I
hope it inspires you that you've heard a
little bit about it you will want to
relax you'll want to have a very
comfortable couch you'll want to be
surrounded by some nice food and some
family and friends and a grandmom
grandmom should come visit while you
watch Indian films
Nikhil another another question okay you
know you've achieved so much in so many
different fields you're a globally
successful and adored actor and producer
you own a cricket team you're a
philanthropist and I think you're a real
role model for all of us my question is
what next and I know that you maintain
that you always want to keep making
people smile but is there a specific
kind of film or project that you really
want to do and haven't yet done I
suppose what I'm asking is what is the
biggest most exciting most motivating
thing on your to-do list if you have one
nickel I've been I'm sorry I mean just
way like I said in the beginning that I
I just work towards my dreams and just
keep running I don't know where I'm
gonna stop and things happen along the
way I started a wanting to be a soccer
player I did economics I did mass
communications my master's in that and
everyone thought I'll do something
intelligent but I became an actor and
and I came I came to Mumbai for a year
because my parents died I told my wife I
said you know we just go for a year come
back I told all my friends they didn't
have be back in a year because they
kicked me out of this 21 years and I'm
still there so things just happen and I
realized the core is really in my job
and as an entertainer and people may
look down upon it at times people may be
happy with it some people may not
appreciate it but I my bottom line is
whatever it takes for me to do to make
you feel happy so if you want me to say
a dialogue I'll do it you want me to
take off my pants and dance I'll do it
see as long as as long
I'm being very honest you know I I can
turn it down and give you a big spiel
about what next and the kind of stuff
that I want to do take cinema to the
next you know stretch the boundaries and
extend the reach of Indian cinema to
global recognition but no I just want to
make a smile so if you tell me I have
this huge dignity of Labor thing in me
then whatever I do you know I've done
street theater and I've done big films
like Robin it was a dream to bring
visual effects into the country my kids
wanted to see a superhero film and so I
do all that and I never think of the
business behind it to be honest and
whenever I come wherever I go whichever
play Simon if people tell me listen
Cheryl can you can you say a line from
this film makes you happy if somebody
tells me can you just get out of this
party that make me very happy I don't
have yeah I want to make a studio I want
to make a stadium I want to make my
cricket team win I I have a lot of
thoughts a lot of dreams and but through
all this
I hope I'm able to make people smile
doing that you know even even even while
I lose when the cricket team I hope
people smile a lot but I'm losing so
that's the only thing and I think if you
keep it basic and simple that's the best
way I think that's so yeah right I know
I want to make an animation for why I
want to remain young to be able to
romance with my son's girlfriend I've
got some stupid ideas to hear okay so
your appeal is universal and it inspires
astounding devotion in fact many of the
audience members here today have
travelled far distances to see you or
this short appearance and also we'd love
to thank you for traveling halfway
around the world to see
so you talked a little bit about this
fanbase that you have among the Germans
and I heard it's also in Poland so maybe
you could talk a little bit about what's
up with that and then I also know that
you you evoke a frenzy that some people
would go so far as to describe as
religious and I was wondering how do you
feel about that and how does it affect
your mission to create honest art and do
you think it's sustainable I mean if all
of this ends how do you think you'll
come to terms with just to being your
honest self just just being human okay
so it's not ending them
I truly believe I'd be very honest I
didn't know how it started I truly
believe this is never never ending and
when you when you say this that you know
you have these people in Poland and you
have in Germany in Japan in Malaysia or
Southeast Asia
you know I have I have woken up I was
shooting a film called one touka for
many years ago in Indonesia in a militia
and you know I was very tired and I was
I went down to the small little house
and I slept on the chair when I woke up
I had this forty family member sitting
and they were all looking at me like
this so I got up and I was very awkward
because you know woke up in some unknown
person's house and when I sleep it when
anyone sleeps you don't look too good
it looks very very very unlock star-like
and I I was little this thing and and
and they had the hands like this they
had a little temple with my picture in
the house yeah and I was I was really
taken aback that the stuff that I do
which is mostly monkeying around falling
down singing just having fun for eight
or ten hours a day on my sets actually
invokes this kind of reaction and the
first thing I realized what you ask me
is that the one thing I will never ever
do is take myself seriously I will never
try to intellectualize what I do I would
like to be as silly as I was when I was
four I would like to do exactly the same
thing that I did 20 years ago because
when I go back 20 years ago there's a
new set of audience which is as silly
and comes and appreciates it right so
you have to keep on doing that I've
never tried to take myself more
seriously like I was reading it here
when when they were showing the that I
have got hundred Awards or be nominated
for so many I've got the Padma Shri and
I have this wonderful fellowship but I
am NOT going to ever become more serious
or intellectual because I have all this
I'm going to do exactly the same stuff
I'm going to have fun and that's why I
believe it will never end it'll never
end because the day I start
intellectualizing and taking myself
seriously my art seriously and what you
asked me just now that you know how are
you going to make sure that your art is
serious and honest I think it's going to
be honest as long as I'm silly and
stupid and childlike and innocent and
naive and an idiot as soon as I've
become an intellectual and I become
serious about this stuff I think I'm
gonna lose it I'm gonna be you know
sitting somewhere in some big hall
giving a lecture about how art should be
the most important thing
I don't want to do that I you know I I
just want to keep on being stupid that's
it I think to all your kids please just
be silly and idiotic there
so speaking of which you've been sitting
around for a long time you had a long
plane ride together you feel like moving
around a little bit
so can I can I have a mic because you
know what because he's not been
introduced to Hindi cinema properly I'm
gonna be a few dialogues no I want I
wanna you wanna fine we have a mic just
any any mic because he's he's got sound
we just need a mic any mic don't tell
him to do that I'm telling you to be
silly don't be that silly
I've made that mistake all right
oh we got a microphone there we go son
because he's been introduced to I'm
gonna teach him some of the Indian
dialogues that I've done from some of my
films yes so you have to say it after me
okay all right so I'm going to teach you
a bit of Hindi so the next time you
watch a Hindi so you understand it a
little bit I do speak German oh yeah
all right side III do I do a dialogue
from
oh darn okay I do dawn dawn dawn is a
film I played a bad guy in so they're
saying you should do it from down again
my bad guy you know about your little
bad guys
so we need to yeah that's that's that's
I'm gonna use that in my next film when
I'm playing a bad guy that's cool yeah
okay so say Don kinda czar to Cara bull
konkey police car here Sonya too long
right okay so I'm gonna do the dialogue
I'll do the actions you just do the
actions with me again alright and just
keep moving amounts that look like you
speak right Don Kazan they love you don
can't resolve to caramel cookie police
gonna here so make him gone cop
economist Kalina he Namib give me that's
that's a makeshift gun ice you think was
it was it cool cool being down Anatomy
okay and I'm gonna I'm gonna request him
because okay okay okay
see that's how Hindi films are they make
you silly in a second all right son I'm
gonna request everyone you guys also
come on stage I'll do a little chammak
challo for you guys you don't have to do
it with us we have Yale's best dancer
Natalia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
goodbye everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
I before I go I really want to thank all
of you for genuinely from the bottom of
my heart this is the most fun I've had
in the last two three months yeah so
thank you Nita
Thank You Isha and all you wonderful
people for coming here and being so
patient and I I feel with all because
they told me this is a serious evening
so I've really really been
intellectually stimulated by this dance
I hope you guys have also been and and
I'm so glad you take little children
into Yale also and but thank you so much
I I can't thank you all enough for your
kindness and goodness god bless you you
do well thank you